after guardians of the galaxy vol 2
because we continue to grow and expand
the traumatic universe we head towards
thor ragnarok solar starts discover
ended impending evil that character's
name is helen she's played by Cate
Blanchett I wanted to take people on an
adventure that keeps people laughing
along the way but it also has those you
know the spectacle of the Thor Hulk
relationship is one that incredible you
can have some of the wildest craziest
most amazing action you've ever seen DMC
hey everybody its Charlie so it looks
like Thor's getting ready to crap his
pants in this teaser let's break it down
a lot of you are also requesting that I
start using music in my videos music
tracks so if you like that just let me
know in the comments or if you want me
to go back to the old system of not
using music that's totally cool too
I know you guys were asking for a
trailer but this is almost better
because we get like a deep dive into the
movie we see what looks like is Firelord
sorter we've seen with a winged helmet
fighting colts in the arena with his
Planet Hulk armor so let's just go
through this footage there's so much
stuff in here there's a new round of the
Doctor Strange DVD giveaway that's where
all this stuff comes from they dropped a
whole bunch of future look footage for
the movies that are coming up so I'll do
a black panther version of this tomorrow
but all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber leave a comment on this video
be sure to click that Bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss anything so the
Planet Hulk armor this is all stuff that
they showed off at Comic Con they
obviously didn't have a lot of footage
because they'd only just started
shooting the movie so they showed up a
lot of concepts footage from stuff that
we all thought that was going to be in
the movie they're like oh yeah you
thought we were going to do this we are
totally going to do all this Planet Hulk
stuff so as far as we know the car is
not the planet in the movie but Kevin
buggy was talking about how they're
going beyond the nine realms that's
basically what this the car type planet
is so until we get some more information
let's just call this the Planet Hulk
part of the movie where they're forced
to fight in the arena for the pleasure
of Loki the Grand Master who sort of
like the collector of this movie he's
another elder of the universe but he's
being played by Jeff Goldblum so he's
going to be really trippy and weird and
here's a real cool thing too is that in
the comics during fan of quest
danos goes to get the mind gem from him
Thanos has to play this really trippy
chess match against him he sort of
tricks him into giving him the gem he's
already collected most of the gems so he
creates this robot Thanos to trick him
is this really crazy story but it's one
of the things that movies are changing
because vision has the mind Jeff
who's the armor though you've seen a lot
of Planet Hulk comic-book stuff but
maybe you missed it at comic-con Marvel
brought his Planet Hulk armor that's
going to appear in the movie to Comic
Con last summer they teased that before
they did their thor ragnarok panel so
it's so funny like they always bring
stuff like that to comic-con way back
when Avengers age of Ultron was
happening before they did their ultra on
panel they brought the Ultron mark 1
armor and showed it off so that will
probably happen again this summer when
they're teasing infinity war stuff
they'll bring some of those props to
show off to everybody so just keep your
eyes peeled at Comic Con this summer I'm
really happy they're letting Thor wear
his winged helmet again and he has a
slightly different armor later in the
trailer it's him in these storyboards
you see way back in the background
there's this giant red figure that he's
looking up at and then you see this
footage a little bit later with him
raising his hammer up on the set so this
might be a version of a scene like this
from the comics where Thor just goes to
confront fire Lords order but when they
were at Comic Con they showed off teaser
footage of Hulk's getting ready to punch
him punch fire Lord sir it sounds so
ridiculous and so amazing at the same
time that kind of gets into the idea of
the working title creature report so
usually the working titles of movies or
a bit of a wink it's something about the
movie but they're also meant to be kind
of funny so creature reports just refers
to all the Ragnarok monsters people like
fire Lords that are just a lot of really
big really powerful creatures then
wrists wolf is going to be in the movie
he was also in that comic-con footage
even though he doesn't really appear any
of this teaser here but the other crazy
thing here is hellah appearing to Thor
and Loki while they're on earth this
might be while they're looking for Odin
so in all the footage that we've seen of
them the actual
footage they're wearing clothes that
look like other humans that looks like
Loki just enchants them so that they
don't stick out like sore thumb I'm
assuming this umbrella here that he's
holding is actually his hammer
Loki's just enchanted it so that nobody
sees it in the comics when he was
walking around this Donald Blake it was
actually just a normal stick so the way
they talk about it the earth is like a
brief part of this movie because all the
movies are slowly tying back to earth
before infinity war but it's not the
biggest part they're going to find Odin
so maybe he'll uh shows up during the
scene but then they go back into outer
space it's largely a space based movie
it's going beyond the nine realm you see
all these other races they probably show
up during those Planet Hulk sequences
when people are watching them fight in
the arena in terms of power-ups there
have been a couple teasers about that
new weapons that swords wielding in the
Avengers infinity war teaser in this
behind-the-scenes picture for the team
Thor Daryl stuff they were shooting all
had a link to that at the end of this
he's actually got his axe and his hammer
right next to him but about most of this
teaser he's wielding the hammer albeit
for like this special hammer here which
looks like it's going to get a lot of CG
maybe it's going to be on fire or
something like that something crazy
because it looks kind of like Hellas
headpiece the way it sticks out but in
the comics he eventually gets the
destroyer armor I don't think he's going
to lose any of his limbs or anything
like that and he's probably not going to
wear the destroyer armor this is still
leather he still kind of chained up so
it looks like he's been held captive and
he's getting ready to throw down with
something really really big well let me
know what you guys think about all this
so far I know everybody's still
wondering how Hulk got into outer space
how he wound up on that planet maybe
that's just Loki trying to get revenge
for what happened at the end of Avengers
because in the comics it was the
Illuminati that shot him into outer
space and a lot of people are just
wondering you know if he's in the
quintet how could the Quinn chick get to
the other side of space [ __ ] is one of
those things that they have not
explained based on the synopsis so far
we only know that Hulk winds up in this
arena on this planet fighting store
that's right in the synopsis so there's
just a lot of stuff in between that that
they have to explain Loki messing with
them is probably just the easiest way to
accomplish that and I know a lot of you
have asked me about post-credit scenes
that's it a few times I feel like
there's going to be some sort of
Guardians type
or credit the amenity and authority rock
will see some hat to Thanos Infinity
Gauntlet maybe Santos quests because
you'll have to start collecting the gems
really soon
I can assure you
it will be absolutely safe yeah in my
collection
even
one down
five to go but I am planning on doing a
fan OHS Infinity Gauntlet comics book
video just to explain some of the paths
and how the Avengers came together in
how they wound up in outer space it's
going to be a little bit different in
the movie but Spiderman was there the
Hulk was there all these characters that
they're doing in the movies were part of
the original Infinity Gauntlet saga so
it's all really cool so as much as
they're changing things they're actually
being very true to the spirit of that
comic book storyline so leave all your
requests for Marvel movie videos in the
comments like I said I'll be doing a
black panther teaser video tomorrow
there's some new Logan footage this x-23
WTF clip so I'll try to do that before
arrow post later tonight congratulations
to yesterday's giveaway winner Kevin
Sanders please private message me on the
back end of my channel so I can get your
contact details there was a new round
that started in this video I'll announce
the winner when I post that Black
Panther video in x-23 Logan posting next
thank you so much for watching here a
couple links for more Thor post-credit
scenes and Avengers infinity war I'll
see you guys in the next video